[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أولئك الذين يصلون إلى مستشفى الشهيد ألاكسا
في وسط غزة أحياء هم
المحظوظون، حيث كانت هناك خمس غارات جوية
هذا الصباح بالقرب من المستشفى، هذا
الفيديو يظهر الدخان المتصاعد من أحد المستشفيات القريبة، وقد
تم إحضار حوالي 110 جثث إلى هنا
خلال الليل، وهذا  في الصباح،
قال مصدر طبي لشبكة CNN، إن المستنقع ممتلئ الآن،
وبقية الجثث ملفوفة بملاءات بيضاء ترقد
الآن في الخارج، وفي ظل حرارة
النهار، يحاول الأقارب التعرف على
أحبائهم، ويؤكد العثور عليهم
أسوأ
مخاوفهم، حيث يقع هذا المستشفى خارج
المنطقة.  من شمال غزة أن إسرائيل
تحاول
إجلاء المدنيين يوم السبت، وأسقط الجيش الإسرائيلي
منشورات تخبر الناس أن كل
من يختار عدم الإخلاء من شمال
القطاع إلى جنوب غزة
قد يعتبر شريكًا
للإرهابي
وأكد جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي في بيان أنه أسقط
المنشورات، لكنه قال إنه ليس لديه أي
نية لاعتبار أولئك الذين لم يتم
إجلاؤهم من منطقة
القتال المتضررة أعضاء في
الجماعة الإرهابية، حتى أولئك الذين تمكنوا من
تجنب القنابل لم يخرجوا من نطاق القتال.  خطر
سمح لعشرين شاحنة من المساعدات
بعبور معبر رفح الحدودي من
مصر يوم السبت، لكن هذا
جزء صغير مما تحتاجه شاحنات المساعدات
إلى غزة لن تغير الكثير. تحتاج غزة إلى ما
لا يقل عن 500 شاحنة يوميا من الوقود والأدوية
والمياه.  في واقع الأمر، لم
تحصل غزة على شيء لمدة 14 يومًا في ظل الحصار الإسرائيلي،
واحتياجاتها العاجلة الآن هي 7000
شاحنة، وتظهر صور الأقمار الصناعية عشرات
الشاحنات المنتظرة على الحدود، وعشرات الشاحنات
الأخرى على بعد ربع ميل على الطريق، وجميعها
غير قادرة على الدخول، كما
تقول جماعات الإغاثة.  أن عدد القتلى يمكن أن يرتفع بشكل كبير
بسبب المرض
والمستشفيات المكتظة
ونقص الإمدادات بدون كهرباء أو
مولد، صاحب المتجر في وسط
غزة يبقي متجره مفتوحًا على
ضوء الشموع بينما تبدو الرفوف
عارية بشكل متزايد، ويقول برنامج الأغذية العالمي إن
نقص الإمدادات الأساسية هو
دفع غزة إلى حافة الكارثة،
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه قتل العشرات من
الإرهابيين بين عشية وضحاها، لكنه يتعهد بأن
عدد الضربات الجوية سيزداد
قبل العملية البرية المتوقعة،
وفي الوقت نفسه تتدهور الظروف بالنسبة لسكان
غزة كل ساعة. سكوت ملان سي إن إن
لندن